what does the Fast and Furious franchise
have in common with Shazam and what does
the inclusion of the daughters of atlas
mean for the future of the DC EU keep
watching for more details you may have
missed in the first Shazam Fury of the
Gods trailer 2019 Shazam was truly
something special the superhero flake is
dramatically different from others in
the DC extended universe and its sequel
is set to follow suit Shazam Fury of the
Gods arrives on December 21st on
Saturday at San Diego Comic-Con 2022
drawing Warner Brothers theatrical
presentation we got our first full
length trailer for The Shazam sequel
starring Zachary Levi in a red and white
spandex suit and his Shazam family the
trailer has everything you'd expect from
this film fun flying sequences mythical
creatures hand-to-hand combat and those
corny kinds of jokes that could only fly
in the world of Shazam Levi is back as a
titular hero with his foster family from
the original film fully suited up behind
him in their superhero form Freddie
Darla Eugene Mary and Pedro are ready to
take on villains hespera and Calypso
there were plenty of homages to the
original film and other DC EU flicks so
let's break down all the small details
you might have missed in the first
Shazam Fury of the Gods trailer Shazam
Fury of the Gods is upping the ante in
terms of adversaries for our titular
hero and his family the movie will see
Billy and the Gang go toe-to-toe with
two gun-like siblings in the form of
calypso and Hasbro who are collectively
known as the dorses of Atlas in the
first official trailer for the dceu
sequel they transfer Powers into their
beings by touching a magical staff and
it's clear that they mean business the
presence of calypso and hespera also
raises some interesting questions about
Shazam Fury of the Gods and the future
direction of the franchise could their
introduction mean that Atlas will make
an appearance as well the Titan has a
long-standing history with Shazam and
his Justice League compatriots in the
comics after all so it's entirely
possible that he's in the DC eu's plan
alternatively the movie might follow the
storyline in which Atlas is murdered by
The Wizard and his sister's mini one to
avenge their old man by causing Havoc
it's also worth noting that Atlas had
three daughters in the DC lore so
hespera and Calypso might not be the
only sisters to appear in Shazam Fury of
the Gods one of the comedic highlights
of the new Shazam Fury of the Gods
trailer comes when Shazam invokes the
famous family Motif that is Central to
The Fast and Furious franchise during a
budget attempt to summon the rest of his
own Shazam family as he sits down with
hespera over a bite to eat I've seen all
of the Fast and Furious movies lately
it's all about family the reference is a
funny one for fans and it's not the
first time a fast and furious joke has
appeared in Shazam but if you don't know
all of the movies you might have missed
that there are at least two strong
Personnel connections between these two
desperate films firstly shazam's family
speech is made to hespera who is playing
played by the grades Helen Miran Miron
of course has been a part of The Fast
and Furious franchise since that cameo
in 2017's the fate of the Furious she's
made subsequent appearances in her role
of matriarch Magdalene Queenie Shaw in
the fast spin-off Fast and Furious
presents Hobbs and Shore as well as
2021's F9 that gives shazam's Fast and
Furious reference an extra meta textual
twists that fans should find amusing
fans are also aware that another new
member to the Shazam world is also a
familiar Fast and Furious face Dwayne
Johnson who's set to make his DC
extended Universe debut in October 2022
with the Black Adam plays the titular
role of shazam's own arch nemesis and an
anti-hero capacity given that both of
Black Adam and fury of the gods are set
in the same sub-franchise of the DC EU
it's not Unthinkable that Johnson may
have some kind of cameo in Fury of the
Gods which is said to come out about two
months before the Shazam sequel hits
theaters further cementing the Shazam
Fast and Furious can action the Shazam
Fury of the Gods trailer doesn't give
away too many spoilers for thus we
should be thankful however some of the
visuals do tease some significant
expansions of the Shazam lore in the
dceu for example this image looks an
awful lot like the rock of Eternity and
this is a big deal with a cool backstory
basically the rock of Eternity is a lair
that is created by the original Shazam
who uses rocks taken from Heaven and
Hell in the comics a mystical Refuge was
used to imprison formidable creatures
including an entity known as the three
faces of evil which is a tri-headed
dragon that made life horrible for the
Shazam family if this is a rock of
Eternity we're seeing in the fury of the
Gods trailer and it does figure into the
film then it's entirely plausible that
the Apple mentioned the Delhi Menace
could be lurking in the shadows waiting
for an opportune time to plan a prison
break of course the lair also serves as
a power hub for anyone who's able to
channel the wizard shazam's
extraordinary abilities so the film
might not feature any three-headed
monsters it remains to be seen how the
rock of Eternity will be portrayed in
Shazam the fury of the Gods but his
inclusion will undoubtedly lead to some
interesting developments the newest
trailer for Shazam Fury of the Gods
shows our hero Zachary Levi Shazam as he
takes on Calypso and hespera after Ares
the god of war came after Diana in
2017's Wonder Woman this would be the
second instance of Our Heroes facing off
with the Immortals fans will notice a
little help comes for the villains in
the form of a dragon that emerges from
the ground looking as Fierce as anything
from Game of Thrones this is probably
the DC Comics version of lardon the
hundred-headed Dragon Atlas Center guard
the apples of the Hesperides while
missing all of its heads Ladawn CGI is
top-notch with the dragon looking like a
formidable opponent for the heroes as it
spits blue fire besides the dragon
viewers will notice another mythical
creature arrive on the scene near the
end of the scene of Billy Batson's
siblings ride black unicorns down the
street while they're all in their human
forms the Shazam family appears
determined as if their going into battle
the moment seems very reminiscent of
Trinity issue 18 where Wonder Woman
Batman and Superman are seen riding
unicorns on the Lost World Scott Taurus
we can't wait to see what other mythical
creatures will be part of Shazam Fury of
the Gods check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more Looper
videos about the DC EU are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the Bell so you don't miss a single one
thank you